يهدد المانيا والغرب بحرب مدمره اذا تم
اعتقال الرئيس بوتين خارج روسيا
تمهيدا لاعاده فتح السفاره والقنصليه بين
البلدين وزير خارجيه السعوديه وايران
يتفقان على عقد لقاء ثنائي
فرنسا تحبس انفاسها امام احتجاجات الخميس
الاسود واستطلاع للراي يؤكد رفض الفرنسيين
لتبريرات ماكرون
[موسيقى]
موسكو حيث حذر نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
الروسي
في الخارج بقرار من المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه ستكون سببا كافيه لاندلاع حرب
مدمره وقال على تصريحاته وزير العدل
الالماني بان برلين ستعتقل بوتين في حال
وصل الى اراضيها قال ان ذلك سيكون اعلان
حرب على روسيا التي ستقوم بدورها بحشد كل
وسائلها العسكريه المتوفره لاستهداف
المؤسسات الالمانيه وجدد من فيديو الاشاره
الى ان قرار الجنائي الدوريه غير قانوني
وغير معترف به
قال امين عام ان الغرب بحاجه الى
الاستعداد لتزويد كيا بمساعدات العسكريه
الفتاكه لفتره طويله قادمه لان السلام لا
يزال بعيدا واضاف سلطان في تصريحات لصحيفه
شمال الاطلسي اكد ان بوتين منخرط في حرب
استنزاف في اوكرانيا وان القطار العنيف في
بخمت يؤكد نيه روسيا لاستمرار في الحرب هو
ارسال الالاف والالاف من الجنود
قال وزير خارج فان قرار بريطانيا تزويد
اوكرانيا بقذائف من اليورانيوم المنظم
يساعد الموقف الى مستويات جديده وخطيره
وسيؤدي الى عواقب وخيمه
هذه خطوه نحو مزيد من التصعيد نحو تصعيد
خطير وكمي وصدرت تصريحات لبعض المسؤولين
الغربيين يقولون فيها انه لا يوجد شيء
مخيف في ذلك وان قذائف اليورانيوم المنظم
لم تكن محظوره وانهم لا يخالفون اي
اتفاقيات لكن الجميع يتذكرون نتائج
استخدام قذائف اليورانيوم المنظم في
يوغوسلافيا والعراق عندما اصيب عشرات
الالاف من المدنيين وجنود الناتو الذين
استخدموا قذائف اليورانيوم المنظم تلك
من جهد يعتد الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في
مجلس الامن القومي بالبيت الابيض جون
كيربي ان واشنطن لا تعتقد ان ذخيره
اليورانيو المنظمه تشكل تهديد من حيث
انتشار الاشعاع وقال كيربي في مؤتمر
الصحفي تعليقا على توريد ضحيه اليورانيو
المنظم ان هذا النوع من الذخيره الشائعه
الى حد ما تم استخدامه لعده عقود
[موسيقى]
شبح تطور الصراع في اوكرانيا لحرب النوويه
عاده للواجهه من جديد موسكو توعدت لندن
بنهايه سيئه اذا نفذت التعهد بارسال قذائف
مصنوعه من اليورانيوم المخضب الى كييف
التعهد البريطاني جلب ردود افعال الروسيه
لو تحققت فربما تنقل الصراع في اوكرانيا
الى مرحله مخيفه الرئيس الروسي حذر من ان
بلاده ستضطر الى الرد وتعمل غرب بنشر
اسلحه تحمل مكونا نوويا التحذير الروسي
شمل واشنطن رغم نفي البنتاجون اي دور
لبلاده في هذا الشان
واضح ان الغرب قرر محاربه روسيا حتى اخر
اوكرانيا ليس فقط بالكلام بل بالافعال اذا
حصل هذا الشيء فستجد روسيا نفسها مجبره
على الرد بما يتناسب مع تزويد الغرب
لاوكرانيا باسلحه نوويه
بريطانيا من جهتها بدات غير قلقه من سيل
الوعيد الروسي بل علقت بسخريه على ما صدر
عن الكرملين ووصفته بالتضليل المقصود
واقرت الدفاع البريطانيه ان جيشها يستخدم
اليورانيوم المخطب في قذائفه الخارقه
للدروع منذ عقود هذه النوعيه من القذائف
خطيره على البيئه حيث قالت الامم المتحده
انها قد تشكل مصدر قلق بيئي في اوكرانيا
لما قد تسببه من امراض بما في ذلك خطر
الاصابه بالسرطان حنان المصري العربيه
[موسيقى]
لا تزال زياره الرئيس الصيني الى موسكو
تثير الجدل حيث اعتبر نائب مديري مكتب
الرئيس الاوكراني ان روسيا لم تستفد كثيرا
من هذه الزياره المسؤول الاوكراني قال في
تصريح له ان بوتين لم يحصل على نصف ما
طلبه من رئيس الصين ولم يكشف طبيعه
المطالب الروسيه من الرئيس الصيني التي لم
يحصل عليها
اتفق وزير خارج السعوديه الامير فيصل بن
فرحان على عقد لقاء مع نظيره ايراني حسين
امين عبد الله حيان قريبا بحسب ما اوردت
وكاله الانباء السعوديه وذلك لتمهيد
الارضيه لاعاده فتح السفارات والقنصريات
بين المملكه وايران
نشطنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي السابق
يهاجم ترامب ويدعو الحزب الجمهوريه لتنظيف
نفسه
الى لبنان حيث وعاده التحركات الى ساحه
رياض الصلح حيث احتجاجا على عدم استقرار
سعر الصرف وعدم اتخاذ الحكومه اجراءات
للحد من الانهيار وضمه التظاهرات هذه
المره المتقاعدي الجيش وقوى الامن
والجمارك الذين حاولوا اقتحام السراي
الحكومي
ورغم ان اكثريه المتظاهرين الذين توافدوا
الى ساحه رياض الصلح كانوا من المتقاعدين
الا ان كبر السن لم يقف عائقا امام
استخدام القوه لمنعه من اجتياز الحاجز
المؤدي الى السراي
الحق بالطبابه والتعليم اضافه الى المطالب
المعيشيه التي زادها السوءن الانهيار
الصاروخي لليره اللبنانيه كانت الجامعه
بين مجموعات اختلفن ثمائها
سرقونا سرقوا جنى عمرنا ومستقبلنا ومستقبل
اولادنا
انا جاي اشارك كطالب ثانوي انه اكثر من
ثلاثه اشهر مدربين والوزير بعده غايب لا
حلول ولا شيء
ولا ممكن نبل هالحكي
وبالتزامن مع تحركات الشارع عقدت اللجان
النيابيه جلسه مناقشه لمسائله الحكومه
ومصرف لبنان وجمعيه المصارف عن الخطوات
التي فشلت باتخاذها
وفيما حضر ممثل عن رئيس الحكومه وحاكم
المصرف غابت جمعيه المصارف دون اي مبرر
احد اجوبه
انه انا اليوم اذا اضطريت اجي اذا ما رحنا
واضطريت اجي عندي عجز بالموازنه راح نكمل
طبع ميل طبعا
بالمجلس قلت له وقفت انا اعترض قلت له اول
شيء مش هيك بيحكى عن طباعه الليره
اللبنانيه لانه واحده من الاسباب الاساسيه
للانه هو الطباعه اسهل شي ندفع معاشات
القطاع الخاص اول شيء القطاع العام اول
شيء بتعيده هيكله القطاع العام تاني شيء
بتوقفوا التهريب بتحسنوا الايرادات
الموازنه لليوم اتقدمت ارتفاع سعر الصرف
بنسبه 12% خلال يوم واحد حرك الشارع
اللبناني لكن الدعوات الى الاضراب لم تلقى
اذانا صغيره ولم تلتزم الصيدليات بقرار
النقابه التي دعت الى الاغلاق احتجاجا على
عدم تسليم الشركات للادويه اما المصارف
وامام الارتفاع الصاروخي للدولار فتراجعت
عن اضرابها المفتوح الذي تشهره سلاحا في
كل مره يقف فيها القضاء بصف المدين هي
المطالب نفسها وحدت اكثر من مجموعه امام
السرايا الحكومي الذي يمثل حكومه ادارت
اذانها الصماء دون اتخاذ اي اجراء اصلاحي
يضع حدا لتعدديه سعر الصرف التي كانت سببا
اساسيا لضرب القدره الشرائيه غنوه يتيم
العربيه بيروت
في تركيا ومع اقتراب موعد الانتخابات بدا
شكل نهائي للتحالف هذه السياسيه يتضح اكثر
فاكثر وفي جديد التحالفات حزب مؤيد
للاكراد يقرر دعم مرشح المعارضه الرئيسي
واردوغان يفشل في استماره احد وزرائه
السابقين
في خطوه متوقعه اعلنت تحالف العمل والحريه
المعارض في تركيا عدم طرح اي مرشح رئاسي
في الانتخابات القادمه ما يعني دعما لمرشح
المعارضه الرئيسي كمال
اجرينا عمليه تقييم شامله لاعلان مرشح من
طرفنا في تحالف الحريه والعمل حيث كنا قد
اعلنا سابقا اننا سنسمي مرشحا لرئاسه بعد
تقييم الشامل نعلن رسميا باننا لن نقدم
مرشحا باسم التحالف لخوض الانتخابات
الرئاسيه القادمه وسنتحمل مسؤوليتنا
التاريخيه في مواجهه نظام حكم الرجل
الواحد القائم حاليا
التحالف الذي يقوده حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي
المؤيد للاكراد اتخذ هذا القرار بعد
اجتماع قياده الحزب الكردي مع كيلج دار
اوكلو الاثنين الماضي حيث يسعى زعيم
المعارضه لكسب دعم الناخبين الاكراد
كممثلا عن تحالف الامه المعارض او ما بات
يعرف باسم الطاوله السداسيه هذا التحالف
تقدم بدوره رسميا الى المجلس الاعلى
للانتخابات بطلب ترشيحك
ملات اتفاقنا
جئنا الى المجلس الاعلى للانتخابات مع
الاعضاء المعقرين في تحالف الامه قدمنا
طلبه ترشيح الرئيس الثالث عشر للجمهوريه
التركيه كماركل جدار اوغلو
في المعسكر المقابل تبدو مهمه الرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان صعبه في الانتخابات القادمه
في ظل دعم جديد تلقاه كلجدار اوكلو وايضا
ما ذكره نائب رئيس الوزراء السابق محمد
شمشك عن رفضه الانخراط في اي منصب حكومي
مع حكومه اردوغان القادمه في حال فاز
الرئيس بالانتخابات
[تصفيق]
قال انه لن يستمر في العمل السياسي ليس له
تاثير محتمل في الانتخابات برايي من جانب
المعارضه خصوصا يوجد استقطاب كبير وهم
يرون انه الوقت الانسب لرحيل اردوغان
في ضوء المستجدات الراهنه يحاول تحالف
الشعب الذي يقوده اردوغان تعزيز تحالفه
وكسب فئات جديده لذلك تحالف مع حزب الدعوه
الحره المدعوم من الاكراد المحافظين لا شك
ان هذه الانتخابات
حياه
اردوغان
لذلك من المنتظر ان نشهد في الايام
القادمه مزيدا من التحركات تجاه التيارات
سياسيه كانت على الهامش يوما ما بغيت جذب
اصواتها لاحد المرشحين زيدان زنجلو
العربيه اسطنبول
في لقاء مع التليجراف قال مستشار الامن
القومي الامريكي السابق جون بولتون انه
يجب على الحزب الجمهوري تنظيف نفسه من
الدار الذي تسبب به دونالد ترامب للحزب
لا اعلم ماذا سيكون رد ترامب لكن بعض من
القاده الجمهوريين يقولون انه لا يجب على
الناس التظاهر لصالحه اظن انه لا حدود لما
يمكن ان يفعله ترامب ويجب ان نقلق من ذلك
يجب على الحزب الجمهوري ان ينظف نفسه من
الضرر الذي تسبب به ترامب وهذه مسؤوليتنا
كجمهوريين
مسار غير معهود رئيس ليس كغيره ممن حكموا
البيت الابيض ترامب امام عقبات قضائيه لا
تنتهي في الوقت الذي ترتفع فيه حمى
الانتخابات الرئاسيه التي تلعب اجزاء منها
داخل قاعه مداوله محكمه نيويورك
قضيه واحده اعادت فتح اربعه الاف قضيه
اخرى
دونالد ترامب الرئيس الذي غادر المنصب ولم
يختفي من المشهد الاعلامي بعد اتهام ترامب
الرئيس وترامب رجل الاعمال جاء دور ترامب
المترشح ليدخل المحاكم القضيه تعود الى
عام 2016 حين اتهمت ممثله اباحيه ترامب
بشراء صمتها خوفا من فضيحه تعكر حملته
الانتخابيه القضيه كانت اقرب الى مجرد
تسويه شخصيه الا ان شهاده صديق سابق جاءت
لتغير مسار التحقيق ميشال كوهين محامي
ترامب السابق اعترف بانه دفع شخصيا 130
الف دولار لتسويه القضيه من اموال حمله
موكله الانتخابيه ترامب لا يواجه التهمه
للمره الاولى الا انه سيقف هذه المره امام
محكمه نيويورك التي يسيطر عليها مدعي عام
الديمقراطي حتى النخ القضيه احيت قضايا
سابقه ومعها جدوى رئيس لا تنقصه المشاكل
بعضها تم تصنيفها كتهم جنائيه وتكفي اداره
واحده لتنسفه طموحاته السياسيه
بايادي مكبله قد يقف اول رئيس امريكي امام
محكمه جنائيه الا ان سمعه رئيس سابق لا
تهم ترامبو انصاره بقدر سمعه مترشح
للانتخابات المقبله
اتهمت ديمقراطيين باستغلال النفوذ لتسيس
القضيه وهي الحجه التي استغلها للاعب
ورقته المفضله المتمثله بدعوه الانصار
للاعتصام انصار الحزب الجمهوري وان لم يعد
ترامب يحظى بالاجماع بينهم الا انهم
اعتبروه نفقا مظلما عبور ترامب منه بسلام
سيقوده الى البيت الابيض من الباب الواسع
فتحت الحدائق في العاصمه اليابانيه طوكيو
وتحديدا في مدينه كويوتو واوساكا فتحت
ابوابها امام السكان والسائحين لرؤيه
مهرجان ازهار الكرز الشهير المهرجان هو
تقليد ياباني للاحتفال بحلول موسم الربيع
حيث اعلنت وكاله الارصاد الجويه اليابانيه
قبل اسبوع ان ازهار الاشجار بدات في
التفتح في طوكيو وذلك قبل عشره ايام من
الموعد المعتاد وقبل سته ايام من العام
الماضي
وفي نهايه النشر مشاهدي نحن نذكر بابرز
العناوين
يهدد المانيا والغرب بحرب مدمره اذا تم
اعتقال رئيس بوتين خارج روسيا
تمهيدا لاعاده فتح السفارات والقنصليات
بين البلدين وزير خارجيه السعوديه وايران
يتفقان على عقد لقاء ثنائي
فرنسا تحبس انفاسها امام احتجاجات الخميس
الاسود واستطلاع للراي يؤكد رفض الفرنسيين
لتبريرات ماكرون
[موسيقى]